all right now that the holidays are over
the catholic charities of southern
nevada i want to remind you that the
community is still in need especially
them so here's a way to give back this
year
hey dick and tom rocky always good to
see you first and foremost here let's
talk about
this catholic charities of southern
nevada and just what you guys do for the
community in general
well uh thank you a big part of our
program that most people know us for is
is food support and so during the month
of december and thanksgiving
we opened up our new dining pavilion in
the parking lot so we created a very
large
structure that creates social distancing
and safety and cleanliness for our
clients to come in
for our daily community meal we served
on an average of about a thousand meals
a day through the holidays and um that's
always a big
big number uh we served a wonderful
traditional thanksgiving meal and a
wonderful christmas meal
so people got a chance to enjoy the
holidays through food as many of us do
our food pantry was very busy gave out i
think 3 000 turkeys for thanksgiving
and lots of additional product up into
the christmas holidays
and then of course our seniors meals on
wheels services 2
400 seniors every day and they got some
holiday meals too in the rotation of
meals so
uh by the grace of god and by the gifts
that so many
of your viewers and others have given us
we have continued to support
and help those in need that is
incredible and i love that
you guys are not only feeding the
community but you're also giving people
a sense of family as well
it is really the the both end yeah
dignity and compassion so
the food is important the food is the
help but the way in which the food's
delivered whether it's to the senior
or in the food pantry or in the
community meal
it's got to be delivered with hope and
dignity and that's what i think
lasts and gives people a chance to know
that even though they're struggling and
they may not want to be here
uh we care and um as i've said to you
before
we don't check religious id cards around
here so all of god's children are
welcome
and how can people continue to help i
know beyond the holidays
you guys are asking for help all year
round we have needs going into the first
of the year we all know that
the challenges of the pandemic are still
among us and we're all
i think hopeful about the impacts of the
vaccine going forward
but it's going to take time and our
clients continue to have needs so
a people that can help us financially
can go to our secure website that's what
i do when i donate to catholic cherries
it's www.calfatjourneys.com
and can make a gift online we're still
not taking volunteers
on site because of the safety issues but
people
can volunteer virtually there are
projects that people can do
making hygiene kits sewing masks and so
there's information
on those virtual volunteer things on our
website
and uh again it's still cold outside
and it's the new year but it's also a
time of challenge
so i ask everyone to please remember the
vulnerable among us and
whatever you can do to help us or help
another not-for-profit that's doing
great work
i know we're all very thankful for that
thank you deacon tom give catholic
charities of southern nevada a call at
702-385-2
or easily just visit their website
catholiccharities.com we'll be right
back